okay we're here for another meeting
about unsupervised machine learning
functionality um and let's remind
ourselves where we had got to we were
looking at learn distribution were you
going to give a demo of anything at him
or you tell me what the agenda is here
yes so I was I'm going to give you more
can always give him home but so the
agenda so I put the four most pressing
item the first one is pretty
straightforward is just a change of name
the second one may be a bit more
controversial is that in learn
distribution mmm
sometimes my distribution I cannot have
the PDF exactly I can just have an
approximation of the PDF let's get some
local okay so first thing is learn
distribution and by the way I assume
this graphic is just an entertainment
graphic this graphic does not relate to
the actual thing that's being learned
right now
no yeah it's just entertainment yeah
okay I mean that cait's a multi normal
so it looks like normal
it's a one-dimensional normal
distribution in the case that case in
the case I gave it yes okay so now what
is this function here so this is the
thing we discussed last time it's a way
to determine the probability to find a
rare event than the event that is given
so if I say we're a probability of
distribution comma one is what is the
probability to generate a sample there
is a PDF lower than what the PDF of one
is so Steph Chandler who was watching
our last live stream or somehow um sent
in a notebook which I think I sent to
you giving someone else yes yes yes
which exactly we'd see that for other
operability will be the second graph not
the first one in that case we don't have
a metric it's not like we define the
extreme Ness of an event not of Phi DS
from zero but how unlikely it is and how
okay so hold on a second so using a
reagent function defined with reference
to an X value this is a way to define
how extreme a value is right with
respect to how far out it is
like I mean oh oh what the integral is
but why is this this here is I mean I
would have expected it to be CDF like
confidence intervals and things
couldn't show that it's the area that
represents this variability yeah well
okay so let's try to remember what and
understand what this actually is
okay so what does this mean this means
the aggregate probability that what is
the one there it's it's a value so you
could query the PDF so you could do PDF
of the distribution so the distribution
Kenard and a value so i put one in that
case okay but that PDF will be some tiny
that the actual PDF will be quite small
the CDF might be I don't even understand
what a CDF is because these are what
this really is is is it's a wannabe CDF
I mean this is a notion of rarer
probabilities so they will want to be
CDF for for a high dimensional situation
isn't it
you know way in a way kind of not quite
I think that it's it's you're right
Stephen it's trying to capture a similar
concept it's probably trying to total up
the probability all the way out not just
a PDF value it's just reference point
use the PDF so your special event it's
one in this case and you know that's the
value of the PDF notice is the event in
the domain of the you know x equals one
right it's your it's your event in the
in the probability space no space or the
events and then that one you know if you
evaluate the PDF at that one you get an
actual value for the PDF yes okay and
now you want everything else to be
what perfectly assumes that that PDF
doesn't have you know big ugly bumps
outside I did sort of you know no I
don't said the the rarer probability
this is if this was a one dimensional
distribution if I'm not mistaken this is
one minus the CDF of that value is that
true no no
look your left tail right tail and you
can also have a Steven when you look at
the sets notable so I think it's in a
highly dimensional you have an ISO curve
basically or Isis defined by that value
for the video yes that's not the PDF
value that you told me that was the
value of the of the thing being measured
not the value of its PDF we're gonna
you're gonna compute the value of the
PDF at that point and now you want all
the XS for which the PDF is smaller
exactly implicitly you solving a sort of
so you want the measure of all X's for
which the PDF is smaller than the PDF
for that X right so right I'm gonna
write down that claim okay and weighted
by the probability measure of all X's
whose PDF is smaller than the PDF for
the X you picked exactly and it's a
uniform measure because it's its
measured according to distribution okay
so it's you can write it as I think go
share yes you can write it using prog
our probability definition and what is
it you know so probability PDF dist
comma X less than or equal to people
mmhmm yeah
PDF dist comma X less than or equal to
PDF or dist comma exhale well yeah and
then X is distributed according to dist
comma no no comma X distributed dist
okay so this is okay so it's very
different CDF by the way yes sorry I
just
this is very different well yes yes I
mean but it's it's trying to capture a
similar Road you know okay but but I
mean is the concept of CDF also useful
because this is the thing with respect
to PDF values rather than well this
assumes you can compare things in your
space you may not have the order of 14
yeah right right right right all right
but also if you look at the picture you
know the fact that this sort of makes
sense I think kind of assumes that you
don't have bad no I take that back it
doesn't assume that oh yeah we can
compute it even with very bad
distribution so the way we do that is
that we do a kind of Instagram of the
PDF we sample is very likely to not work
very well you know for the pyramid yeah
because those those PDFs this is gonna
lead to integrals and sounds that are
very tricky it's just fine but I like
this definition I understand this
definition okay so now the question is
you want an actual function rather
property of the distribution yes so I
mean there will be a property for
example anomaly detection in London and
I'm a detector function you could ask
what is the word probability for this
example I was think of doing
function as well as you see here and
that's one thing and certain thing in
the past we talked about total error
probability and a strongly thing we
should just call it a rare probability
because it's simple and because it's
more accurate of what it is because
actually as you can see on the line of
code you typed you speak of probability
not as total probability even though
it's computed by totaling something so
that's a two points the name and if we
want we can already put it in 12 as okay
oh okay so hold on hold on so you're
telling me that if I do this and this
thing is a picture of a cat that
result if it's a dispersion of images
yes well by the way
no land exhibition won't have the
property where are probabilities so
there's a function with the only way to
get it it's only an anomaly detector
that you have properties because we
reserved you know the kind of sub value
type thing in land distribution to
condition distribution or do other
things what what conditioning can you do
for example if you have two viable you
can say X equal one you cannot currently
do it but in the design we thought a
long time ago we figured that could be a
nice extension so then it will return so
what you're saying then is that I could
say LD of X I don't even know what X is
anymore here what the heck is that
yeah won't be X this would be LD okay
this is y also we don't like it in 12 we
didn't properly define how to specify
the viable the simple case would be I
mean you could do let's say you could do
in that case you could just do LD of one
I mean it's just you need mention on
that case but let's say it's be
dimensional you could do open curly
brackets and could one command missing
for example that we went away it's that
great way no it's not a great way all if
I'm not mistaken what you want is things
like less than 1 for example you're
gonna need a whole I mean that's another
type of transformation of distribution
we could have right but I mean it seems
like what you really need is a selected
specification there
that's something I mean now we're going
in another another path okay okay fine
but but okay so I'm just trying to
understand
realistically okay I mean this rarer
publicity thing seems pretty ornate to
me that is what is yeah I mean if I get
a what do you think the answer is going
to be okay for error probability let's
say I show a picture of a of a um you
know I think we talked about rainbow
cats last time Wow okay so let's say I
show a a standard picture of a cat the
grumpy cat for example of which there
must be many pictures out there yeah um
so you're saying I mean what kind of
values were and compare that with a a
you know a cat that's had its fur died
in a rainbow or something terrible like
that
um what um I li interpret printable
result it's it's like the p-value so if
you get something like 0.01 only 1% of
chance that if you are sampling
something with distribution you have
something rarer so it mean it's quite of
a rare event
I mean it's called a vey extreme event
so it's for you quite confident that
it's an anomaly but it's not an in
distribution example that's so this was
definitely for an addiction right that
we thought of this concept okay so for
ordinary distribution okay so let's
imagine that this was just a normal
distribution okay so just so I
understand so so I should be able to
just compute this if I'm doing so let's
imagine I do this um and here I've got
let's say if you use if you use n
probability will for sure work okay
I mean it works for probability of all
the normal distribution
probably one probability it's definitely
just a few pigs more exotic stuff only
just okay okay it's you know okay so
then let's say that that's value one for
example okay so that's saying what
that's saying is that that the integral
so let's let's let's compute this with n
probability 33 because because that's
the PDF at x equals 1 which is 1
standard deviation right this
distribution am i right
so one standard deviation so that's the
total probability this literally is the
tail stare you know because this one you
know it both tails this is double tails
ya both tails
okay so so for example here if I go out
to like 5 Sigma or something
well this is kind of interesting I agree
it's kind of interesting so this is okay
but the notion of one tail to tail
there's just no choice because as you
generalize this there's the notion even
if you're dealing with cat pictures of
where the tail is making it in if you
have a very lucky v'n a 2d one you know
very low dimensional still think of that
value that there can be a very bumpy
curve you know let's let me look for a
multi normal distribution do we have
multi normal yes okay so um so let's say
I wanted two dimensional normal the
situation then why don't she use by
normal it's gonna be fine then vector of
of free means well and then covariance
matrix can I just do that no no you need
to define the matrix Steven maybe like
identity matrix of s3 mm-hmm right
for instance in which case there's no
dependence like this right and then your
special point has to leave in our space
so dusty X DX still one it doesn't
support vector variables yeah it needs
to but it doesn't so so what do I have
to say and the same for them
so one one problem I see with this is
that in high them in very high
dimensions all of the volume is is at
the edges of our so so that the the
actual probability which is the PDF
times the element of volume might be
very different today it's all in for
physicists here it's older in the phase
space so to speak it's all in the it's
some it's the entropy not the free
energy or something I mean you're saying
it's it's just a
but I mean isn't that right your point
is there's a big integral that is it
it's just there's a lot more volume yeah
so what I mean yeah so what it's very
low weight yeah but I mean this is a
problem that you find in MCMC
integration or simulation where like the
actual density of the distributions has
nothing to do where you actually find
some pose because you you might for
example where the density is very small
but the density times the elements of
volume is larger right sure I mean it's
misleading yeah right so okay so like
the five Sigma but just so I understand
here this is like five Sigma okay so is
there an easy way to understand this so
this is like ten to the minus five and
this is ten to the minus seven so for a
normal distribution this is saying a
single point out in this normal
distribution so this is going against
what you said because this has lots of
volume there there's the
three-dimensional thing the shells the
spherical shells are you know Oscar IDR
yeah but you only picked them you stay
at this the center for y&z
it's like zero zero you're not going
very far out reapply five by square root
of three introduce M number I think
because much about this quote of three I
think you'll be the same number he says
that if you just have independent
distribution so it's equivalent of one
yeah actually not actually no sorry no I
understand what you're saying this is a
product just okay fine all right
anyway so first question here is whether
we want a single rarer probability it's
an interesting idea it's an interesting
idea so fundamentally you're going to be
able to give a picture of a cat and say
rarer probability of that and what do
you think it's gonna do in practice if
it's been trained on images for example
is the number gonna be 10 to the minus
100 or what what's it gonna be no no no
actually she give a classic image it
would be a completely reasonable number
like 0.5 0.7 0.2 if it's good
distribution of course of our other
images so try something that gets crazy
I mean only get crazy if it's really an
anomaly how about we call this to make
it not seem like it's as well I guess
this is a distribution here so you know
you're getting it over I mean you
already know you're doing something
estimated because you've got a
distribution there right yeah
sample from any normal distribution and
you give it the code you have it will
give very reasonable things
what if examples if you don't well ten
times from the machine normal
distribution and then you compute the
right side
typically a single above 0.1 and but if
I go here and I say random variate
exactly any ten times and then you feed
it to your thing okay so now what I do
here is I go about all of them would be
about zero point one because it's just
sample ten and five actually average
would be 0.5 because first sample and
another sample there's no reason that
one should go right is taking forever
unless there's a problem in the
computation but yeah okay so let's say
so let's look at the wow this one's that
are 0.99 but let's look at should we
look at the histogram of these that was
very instructive let's look at the mean
actually actually it's going to be a
flat distribution I think because your
sample yeah I think in that case is
going to be a flat distribution the most
important point is that these randomly
sample points have a 50% their-their
error probability is 50% yeah yeah so
it's weights a good thing to know if
data point is in distribution or out of
distribution all right if it's out of
distribution which it's definitely an
anomaly right exactly question don't
even need any measures oh okay what I
meant by a solution is not sampled from
this distribution but in the same space
oh all right
very probability it is let's do it
so and let's support it for I mean
obviously we should support
for our ordinary distributions as well
as learned distributions you have to be
very careful when you add all these
properties it's expensive to make it
work well so let's make it this
experimental and we can make it work
badly for right now okay I think this
this why we it's it's it's it's that's
why we limit you know that the number of
things it's it's it's costly to add now
I understand but I mean we're okay I
mean I can I mean I would like to add it
following distribution so maybe I could
document it just following distribution
look we've got it let's see whether we
can get just this definition in there
even if it runs really slowly just so
that it's you know instructional
instructive so to speak I think I mean
what you're basically trying to say is
this is a modern version of p-value this
thing it's a version of I don't know and
the question is that you have the exact
when you use probability and then you
have an improbability which uses
different metals so technically you
would think look at at her supporting
greater probability and rarer and
probability but I don't think that's
alright let's go on I mean okay let's
support this for learn distribution it
will be really nice to support it for
some of these basic cases like normal
distributions but you can do did you
know the other thing to do is to just
give those as examples to make you know
that's the definition just use the
definition if you want to illustrate it
with a neck you know more understand
okay
um by the way I'm gonna save this in my
let's see do I have a machine learning
must have a machine learning
well we haven't known that framework
okay
I'm going to save this in a gender loan
distribution to in the neural networks
subdirectory okay do we have anybody
project managing here mazing she said
yeah yeah um okay
actually am i right about the the stress
so is it Andrea or Andrea in your case
it's Andrea good okay that's what I
predicted um all right so other actually
even more controversial design the next
step next agenda next so the story is
PDF okay actually explain the history of
the uncertainty option so this is in any
option a string option is an option that
shouldn't be that it's true it's true
but I remember we talked about that and
we kind of made an exception and we were
even money to make it experimental so
but I never managed true as you want
I mean we've agreed that we're going to
have this mean around function that will
give an around result yes yes is this
around result or is it something
completely crazy
being around right now it's press-
because it's old stuff but it will be
around and I talked a bit with Jose and
it was kind of receptive to a
uncertainty type option I mean he said
the argument everybody says that
normally an option shouldn't change the
head of the results but that okay I feel
a different suggestion be a really
different suggestion okay why not simply
since this is the accuracy property why
don't we just have an accuracy around
look
well you're gonna tell me it has 300
different things in it yes other way did
we a week giving up on classifier
measurements and Oh fantastic no and
we're going to tell what about
information is that different from
classifier information that's different
different but we are giving a book less
for information yes all right well we're
turning it into pure purely information
yes okay so your point is that there's a
good detail open details of Sonia okay
my gosh they also potent stingy okay I
know I mean it could be I mean this
would I guess is decision will change a
lot of thing in the system but
personally I find it pretty nice to ask
here is a results because in the past
what was precision I wish that table was
broken up into digestible chunks of real
things that makes sense together for
truly fit alpha wedding is not you know
phonetic is there's a winner out yes
okay
okay so so let me talk about what I
think the obvious way to do this is okay
I claim the obvious way to do it is just
to have a an argument here because
here's why it's like having entity value
right entity value if I look at entity
value it's going to be everywhere I mean
I do a lot
of you know statistical estimation of
stuff okay but look look at the entity
right it has a notion of an annotation
and the annotation is precisely this
kind of thing does it have a physical
quantity does it have a unit blah blah
blah and I suspect we will add to entity
value something which returns around
numbers see what I'm saying
yeah
you know this is all kinds of metadata
like the date on which this property was
was given and so on right
which other okay so classifier
measurements so for example where a
probability also as this uncertainty
value I mean of course I won't
necessarily document it but it has it
because it's a it's an estimation and I
understand but so presumably many of our
statistical functions can return this is
that correct I mean not now but but
should be able to return this Roger yeah
I'm thinking of hypothesis test is
probably too earliest targets the other
things are more substantial in terms of
changed workflow because like an overt
type stuff or you're thinking about or
what well anawa is not even a system
function so
um no but if you're gonna change mean
for instance if you're gonna change no I
don't think that's why that's why I'm
suggesting that we want okay so let me
explain another point okay
the computation what am I trying to say
given certain of those quantities can be
computed using the formalism up to
fourth order or whatever that we're
using and others cannot is my
understanding
oh it's we can represent well what am I
talking about you know yeah and maybe
that's a different point I mean we can
we can accurately represent know
that's a different point I'm sorry hello
maybe Jose should be there I don't know
if he's available walking around no yes
I think it would be useful if he's if
he's forgot to ask
that is a deteriorated I lost somebody
here
you
no but for instance there there are in
but a more substantial redesigns okay so
for instance when you estimate the
distribution you ask you know like you
estimate the distribution parameters do
you want to get a sense of the you know
the uncertainty for these and so right
now we don't we don't have a a fit
function if you like but we have we have
estimated distribution because it's the
cleanest or find distribution parameters
it's the cleanest term in terms of
fitting workflows what I mean find hit
could return something with errors to
not find fit because that doesn't even
have a sort of statistical model
associated with it but fine model fit
does
okay
um so what but I like about the auction
is that we can really add it everywhere
now that I understand I understand that
but but
you
um however the name is hopeless
I'm not keen on this because I mean
basically what's gonna happen is
I mean that was the first thought about
what we do with mean there was a reason
why we only want to have mean around
because I as I recall we can't do
kurtosis around for some reason but
maybe if Hosea is found it will be able
to explain that well I think moments are
easy to do because it fits that model
ketosis is the ratio to moments yeah
look I mean it sort of works but it's
you know it's it's it's a it's a totally
different distribution it's it's it's
just sure
can I mean I managed to do the 24 like
all these lists like this kappa
coefficient this blah blah blah worst
case scenario you simulated yeah I
understand
doing some not a color thing right yeah
bootstrapping actually so in that case I
would just bootstrap the data set so in
terms of where we are we did with the
other statistics framework where we use
a lot of bootstrapping
isn't in hypothesis testing
dose like the test statistics had very
complicated distributions for which you
know they don't in most cases they they
are not actual sort of parametric
distributions we don't have them
and so there's bootstrapping used to get
derive all the probabilities and so on
yes
okay in any case the main point here is
I mean there's a there's a ton of
functions I mean look if we're going to
have an option the obvious option is
something like include uncertainty or
something
you
generate uncertainty sounds bad
you
see matter no just include seems good
yeah but the problem with that is
[Music]
I mean maybe we want to use the around
brand name so to speak
um
[Music]
all right well anyway I mean that's a
possibility I suppose we could
experimentally start doing in a few
functions I'm not sure it's the right
design and I really want to talk to Jose
before we commit to that but if you
insist on putting something in I would
start off putting that in well because
we can answer it everywhere but you know
I understand to stop putting it in it'll
be a winner but I think I want to check
this with Jose before we commit to it
now
what do you so now I came to their
because when I compute a PDF on this
learn distribution because sometimes as
a processor that actually stochastic and
I kind of need to do that I mean it's
really practical thing to what of that
then might be every not exact anymore so
it's a Monte Carlo estimate of the PDF
when you create and so that would mean
to have options to PDF as well such as a
certain C or some max iteration type
thing to control the quality of the
estimation so what have we done on other
in other areas this must have come up
another place yes no we don't have yeah
we don't have to breathe in twelve but
you know I think there would be
something very local to learn
distribution and I don't think that that
should be documented on a PDF in that
case should it be part of learn
distribution rather than part of PDF in
other words is that an attribute of the
learned distribution rather than an
attribute of the PDF s of the PDF
computation it is
well is it it's it's it's an attribute
of the fact that yes the PDF is a crisp
thing there's nothing uncertain about
the PDF pure and simple yeah it's only a
lens reason
so no no I understand but why the max
iterations is it naturally associated
with the learnt distribution or is it
naturally associated with the
computation or PDF from the learnt
distribution it's the Montecarlo
way of computing things right and the
only way that I mean we have desmet as a
method in like an expectation but then a
user specifies that he wants Monte Carlo
method and then he knows that every
evaluation on an expectation will give
you a different value and here if you
just have a PDF on the learned
distribution using the Monte Carlo under
the hood it every different different
value of the PDF okay so listen listen
this is something we've had to worry
about in a bunch of other machine
learning functions we do random seeding
right we have the random seeding
function to prevent that issue right so
that we so that we are deterministic
that's really to calm the mind because I
don't know I think it's a bit cheating
you know people that use PDF rajee's or
SM reso they are happy they think it's a
PDF but it's actually not okay
but but there's all kinds of other
reasons why the I mean this is something
we've had to do for machine learning
because they want it to be repeatable
yeah I know everybody wants that I'm the
only one that thing it's putting your
head under the sand to give you
confidence that your result is good but
actually yes right I mean it's it's yes
I mean but it's at like a numerical any
numerical scheme it gives a definite
answer um let's see did Jose just join
us yes okay so a 10 wants to you know
make put around into everything in
particular he wants things like
classifier measurements to be able to
generate it
let's see so we're talking about options
that could be included in a bunch of
functions that would generate around
results we did talk about that before
can you remind us what was said and what
you know why we decided that for example
kurtosis around made no sense well when
we discuss this we discussed only a few
functions we didn't have in mind the
possibility of propagating it through
many places so I don't think we
discussed in the in the past an option
yet but I think it's a good idea to have
a a common option that will switch a
variety of functions all right wait we
have some how the idea that we don't
control the output of things from
options but I think in this case we
probably should well one could argue
that this is like a precision goal so we
have a goal we have a bunch of functions
you could say you know the precision
goal is determining the output of
something because it's determining the
number of digits of precision that it's
going to generate also that if around
work see meaningless within all
functions then the fact that it's a
different head doesn't matter that much
right but it won't for a while right let
me point out that in terms of head
changing you know there are real results
there are complex results that's a head
change true for precision you're right
it could be like a arbitrary precision
number or machine number it's kind of
low they have the same hat but okay so
what should we call this option
I mean include uncertainty is the
current leading contender although I
don't like that because I think it's got
to be clear that it's generating I mean
it will be nice to use around and
and is this always a boolean will we
need some sort of additional information
of whether you want a pictorial or a
list or something oh gosh what do you
mean by that
you mean how much for example how much
correlation to include is that the kind
of thing you mean yes I mean whether
there's a some flexibility
additionally to adding it's true could
have like one sanitation three
standardization like it's true that
different or you say like like in
physics or in other field they might
have different convention about what
exactly exactly
some deduce 3 Sigma 2 Sigma actually
just one or two no but there is a point
you know
are you view them as sort of independent
you get a bunch of scalar around or do
you get a vector around which has
correlation some sense of dependence
well and also this point about are you
giving the 90% confidence interval or
what something else oh yeah so the
optional may need to be something more
general than a boolean yeah I understand
but this idea saying that you're giving
the precise results well I mean you're
saying um I mean it's this is horrifying
but something like results type you know
best estimate seems to convert a round
object maybe to go from one cell
addition to to some radiation or
something like that that's an
interesting idea how would you do that
josè assuming that it was normal
distributed how would you tell a round
object to convert itself to being three
sigma for example set confidence
interval and around and then command and
9 and would set us in sea to your point
you know 90% of all for example well
that's an analogy to set precision
no because you don't change the
precision there so this would just be no
in that case you change the precision
right change the visualization of the
representation right so that's one here
no if you if you if you view it as the
analog if you say set confidence level
or Sigma level or something like that
then yes but I think I understand at the
end so here we are not changing the
actual object we are just changing how
to express it
it's more like a form so this is one of
the things that would go into our own
form I didn't quite understand that but
I mean what we're saying here so the
confidence level is is to express that
instead of giving Sigma you want to see
the result with 3 Sigma but the object
itself is still the same one the object
itself is still kind of like a
distributor distribution but we display
it you know 1 Sigma right right exactly
so it always contains inside 1 Sigma but
we may want to see if the signal you're
saying I see you're saying that that it
is merely an around form option right so
so the plan was that it it's also
accepted in input because you can say
something like 0.6 confidence levels 3
so that means I'm actually giving you 22
how would we give that how we specify
that a person option confidence level
input fully around for around yes
we also in this plot and so on it would
interpret although around and what do we
do about the varied case who say are
they confidence ellipsoid so what I
haven't prepared for that I I've never
seen that women are you asking for the
plotting or are you asking for what if
we guess the question what's there so
confidence intervals make sense in the
1d case but that's not in the
multivariate case but the multivariate
normal is an ellipsoidal it has
ellipsoidal ISO curves isosurfaces so
one often gives you know ellipsoidal
confidence values so you get you know if
you want you want to find the ISO curve
let's say the 2d case ISO curve such
that the tale outside of that curve is
you know point zero five well you know
guess what we just discussed this
effectively here we did but it's a
different take on it because it it uses
this implicit thing of looking at the
actual value at that curve as well so
there's one more level of implicitness
what is the rarer probability is another
level of yeah yes because there's a PDF
inside of it there yes I agree I guess I
would have to give independent levels
for the different axis okay person we've
got several takeaways from this one is
that that ignore state their dependence
what about an option like uncertainty
handling a none means don't even don't
worry about it I mean I don't know
things like this perhaps
so behavior we have missing can you look
at the options we have related missing
here in Israel you know and question
mark cast missing asterisk or asterisk
machinist ask
you're suggesting a uncertainty we have
your essence I'm not sure that's quite
right because that suggests how what the
behavior is when an uncertainty is
encountered like when a missing is
encountered oh I see yes yes you're
right um let's see this is about how to
generate uncertainties see I hate the
word uncertainty generation it's kind of
like you know it's kind of like some
kind of you know political plan or
something generate uncertainty so people
will I don't know for whatever I it just
doesn't seem that's not what we want I
mean that's not this has to do with
whether you account for uncertainty in
the output which is more like include
uncertainty but as you say that they're
very um they don't quite understand
correlation thing because the confidence
interval thing this will be handled
afterward which what Jose said an option
or you know we can imagine when you do
list plot you can do confidence about
0.9 and over arrow bars we adapt to
right lens or stuff like that so is
there really some way and we think we
have to specify for how the study is
computed maybe you understand well are
you going to be able are you going to be
interested in correlations at some point
so that you will have a difference
between returning a list of arounds and
an around of a vector with a matrix of
correlations
[Music]
okay so it's kind of the level at which
we don't we have something sorry for
some of the fitting functions don't we
have something analogous to compute
uncertainty no well I mean yes I mean
that's what some of the properties
explain give you
but but it's not cool all these various
names compute uncertainty is clearer
than include uncertainty because it
makes it clear that it's something in
the output see what I'm saying
you
you
that's what I recommend of these ones
what do you guys think
no luck bulls I don't like include
uncertainty because I think include
suggests it's an inclusion of you know
including the effects of uncertainty
that came in the input so to speak
whereas this is just from from nothing
compute the uncertainty like returnest
until yo yes right
I'm in other words so that will be my
recommendation for now
anybody got any better suggestions okay
sounds good to me um so when our
livestream is saying they prefer
uncertainty handling well their other
one their other suggestion is
uncertainty Sigma I don't think we can
quite say Sigma but uncertainty see
that's not right though instead a
lowercase Sigma or an uppercase Sigma
the uppercase Sigma is a covariance
matrix as opposed to the lowercase
variants standard deviation one thing
that I was thinking is that if you're
gonna have a numerical confidence
interval that itself has its I mean it I
don't know if it in at the end would
have to say but that itself has its own
uncertainty so this becomes very meta in
the sense that competing that confidence
interval accurately I in some situations
can be very costly and and itself that
number has an uncertainty right but okay
so let me just cover one more thing so
in a round form okay
um are you prepared on have a round form
doesn't seem to be in here yet um are
you seriously proposing that we actually
have a thing I mean this is oh my gosh
what is this when you give the
confidence interval you know you could
just be a tooltip when you when you past
your mouth over there around there's a
kind of an explanation
90% column that's instance he I don't
know some stuff like that you know in
explainer of what around these
well that is getting very precious
because the fact is around is a is a
messy I mean is a it there's a very
beautiful calculus of around that
represents an approximate uncertainty
and if you try and tighten it up it's
going to fall apart
if I'm making sense it's just an
uncertainty that satisfies certain rules
of propagation the interpretation of
that uncertainty whether it's a 90%
thing whether it's a system at you know
whether it's somebody's estimate of how
wrong it could be meters or in normally
it's not it's not I mean that's just an
approximation
um I mean I I don't know even what you
know what the heck this is I mean it's
some kind of assumed confidence interval
or something well I don't even know what
that you Jose you get what I'm saying I
mean this is so because it's not normal
distributed you know it's a fake
when you say this but betting are wrong
I'm sorry at least with two arguments we
are always assuming that it's normally
distributed that's true
so in a two argument case it is normal
this is sort of I mean it's it's fake
but it's you know it's it's you know
what it is so I mean this is more like
displayed confidence interval that
correct
that's what you want and that's
similarly what you'd want in terms of
list plot is a displayed confidence
interval for list plot is that right I
think this is important yeah because
clearly there's different culture but
what you show okay um so you're saying
what happens when you mix cultures in
the world no but but Tim I mean your
point is represent anything it's not the
the fact that it says 3 plus or minus
point to write that point two could be a
90% confidence interval it could be an
anything else
it doesn't matter the the formalism is
invariant with respect to which of those
it means isn't that correct
not really when we do propagation
it's always 1 Sigma now a round form
we'll be able to say I want this with 3
Sigma so it will print with triple Sigma
and then in parenthesis saying 3 Sigma
or some say that ok so you always need
to know that you are using 3 Sigma so
one of the things here is like if you're
gonna get an interval out that Sigma
there just specifies the distribution
the mean and the Sigma specifies the
distribution in the simple case now what
how do you want to get an interval out
of that
you want to cut it off
you know do you by default cut it up
with one Sigma and what Etienne says
well some some groups will want to
signals for three Sigma's okay hey
listen in in a round form are we
planning a great big association of
properties or are we planning a few
options I was planning to model decent
number phone
so we'd have fewer chips I don't know
how many of these there are do we need a
design discussion about a round form by
the way and if so can we make sure we
bring this stuff into that yes okay so
the idea was to have a default type
setting for around initially and perhaps
not having our own forum in there or did
you know what we can get in that right
so yeah so having working a lot on the
typesetting needs of our own itself not
so much on on our own firm yet that's
quite beautiful actually what's going on
quite beautiful and try to use large
numbers or no number itself yes so it
will switch to oh that's magnificent so
it will switch to my god scientific form
a Berber women why is that the right
answer this says one and two wise it was
it 10 and 20 there oh because it took
another digit why did it take another
digit why is it not
one less digit and then plus two minus
one I actually think this is quite nice
by the way what you have here is quite
nice but but this is kind of overstated
classic notation Oh two-digit the idea
is that we don't want to have the error
with too many zeros so when it goes
above thing is four zeros or five zeros
then it switches to this notation with
parentheses no I know but what I'm
asking is why didn't it chop one of the
zeros off at the end
oh because remember our rule of 35 if if
if the error is more than 35 the
crazy yes but I'm it's right this looks
good
a rule of 35 yes should we all remember
the rule of 35 of course of course it
makes it 1 2 2 4 & 5 gonna perhaps
different behavior isn't it because now
they are above 35 it shows only one
digit so that's an one of the are there
things that you will control from a run
form so what is the boundary because
people discussing the books whether you
have to switch one to two digits in at
15 or 25 or 55 yeah what it just did
there is kind of kind of interesting now
if I say five point six seven my
goodness sorry about that I mean we saw
the rounding is 57 what's that
the rounding is 57 we can still see it
yes okay I'll send you this case Jose um
okay okay by the way that does suggest a
testing protocol from the testing folk
that that failed suggests you know for
you um is there something that people
know the rule of 35 is this like you
know I was a young physicist you know
that there's a rule of 35 when you write
your lab report I was taught as a rule
of 15 yes now I don't know whether
that's the standard terminology that I
must admit that's probably perhaps
something from Spain but but it's true
that all books will discuss how many
digits you want to have and some books
will say it's crazy to have more than
one two and so we we do need a way of
controlling how many digits we want
focus of what what what field is this
experimental error for example I could
look in the I have a conveniently I have
a particle data book on my oh my what do
they talk about this they do talk about
done yes and and actually I've taken the
rule of 35
they mentioned 355 that's their border
they actually do look at 3ds okay yeah I
see they have a whole section here on
the stuff um you never noticed it before
I think they added it since since I
first got these books in 1973 um Wow
okay well maybe I didn't pay attention
to this section but I don't think they
had this particular section um
propagation of errors okay they do I
think they will discuss some of this oh
gosh they're typesetting us just
clarified
okay well anyway um Wow
well they've got all kurds around them
things in there now okay
um alright I think we're going to have
to wrap this up but let's just review
what else um our live stream the physics
PhD who has never heard of the rules 35
good well I feel better now um
two other things I wanted to discuss was
how to represent amazing data we didn't
finish last time and then the names of
the super function to do missing
imputation last time we went a bit crazy
about changing the names if you scroll
down actually you will see this is a
notebook of last time as well so if you
scroll down down down down ego what a
bit crazy with a bunch of name for
imputation yes and I didn't like missing
imputation very much yeah fill missing
seemed nice yeah but now what about the
function the trains right so missing
feeling is a bit weird
missing feeler function is super weird
in my opinion I agree still missing
seems fine but okay hold on hold on what
functions do we need here fill missing
so do we give
presentation because it's also why shadi
was there and and no let's just talk
about this for a minute and then we'll
try and get one or two minutes on the
missing thing and then we got to go to
something else um ah so what is the
issue here so we're the main point is
Phil missing is a much better that let's
try to avoid the word imputation because
I think it's a you know it's it's not a
particularly well known word it's hard
to understand it sounds like an
accusation so to speak you know you
impute this motive to such and such is
the most common use of that word I'm
making sense
whereas filling in missing values is a
very well understood thing so what
you're concerned about
is that we want to given data we want to
have a function okay
one important thing actually I'm not
even sure so in the current idea is to
both learn from the data you're given
and model and then use this model to
impute the missing values yes we could
also imagine a function that doesn't
really learn for the data that just has
a bunch of billion pined for images for
techs and I feel that like Phil missing
for example maybe more one of this
function maybe you'd give just one at
that point so I can imagine people using
just one data point if I put one image
and they're still missing how do you
feel and that's not what this whole
thing's in painting
exactly exactly but I guess we could
tune your eyes to other things and
that's not exactly what this function
although I guess it could be I don't
know it should be why not have some pre
pre trained or maybe new functions we
are kind of a the most specific function
that there's more for statistical people
like okay you learned them a little from
the daytime then you impute it's more
the lower-level function and then we
have the same thing that that's whatever
I need to do no but I think I can
classify okay so the only difference is
classify you can give it a built in
classifier the point is I mean you know
what you're saying is we could have said
that classify if you just give it an
image we'll assume a certain classifier
function which is the image identifier
let's say and use that which i think is
over you know it's over
overreaching whereas here yeah you're
saying it is reasonable to give a single
instance of data I can imagine wanting
to do that sure yeah I'm sure you would
use like that in six months when you're
forgotten
absolutely no no no no I mean put
replace a scratch but we don't have a
good representation of missing values in
images do we that's what we at
what we're talking about as matter of
fact in like an hour when we're talking
about the annotation framework so let's
both your representation of missing
values and that should be this should be
part of the annotation meeting and if
you're not in that meeting a TN you
should be I am okay well then let's wrap
this meeting and okay we're actually
doing another livestream meeting for
those on our livestream we want to break
these apart so that they are archived
separately oh boy this is a large
meeting about formal symbol design and I
think I need to go to that so um so
let's let's bring up this thing about
representation of missing data again in
the annotation section annotation
meeting and then we've still got one
more thing to resolve about these the
name for Phil missing makes sense yep
okay all right see some of you again in
the next meeting